I remember walking around the beetle and
and I remember seeing it I saw it is
exactly as if it was there when it
wasn't so it's gonna be housed right
here there's gonna be a house here and
there's gonna be and then we have the
plans and then we worked with the
builders and then suddenly booming now
it's that just as we saw it there was
someone in Samuel elite and I've done
quite well in property over the years
and in this video I want to credit my
dad because I remember when I was little
and there was someone that said seeing
is believing and I've heard that quote
many times throughout my adult life
seeing is believing in other words all
but me there when I see it I'll believe
it when I see it I can't see it then it
doesn't happen it doesn't exist it's not
real and I remember my dad saying
sometimes you have to believe it in
order to see it and you have to see it
in your mind you have to visualize it
instead before you get manifested before
you see it physically another time I
thought that sounds really spiritual it
sounds a little bit OCA's pocus but you
know what as I became successful in
business I realized that actually that
was true and now sometimes in the same
way that my dad told me that and it
helped me and it manifested some of my
success maybe when I say the same stuff
so many people I just I just posted it
on Instagram
and people were sort of like laughing at
it and saying this is stupid this is
personal development hocus-pocus
American claptrap come on Samuel just
give us some property tips and
guaranteed every single person that said
that is not successful in property and
here's why one of the things I realized
as a property developer is that actually
this is the case for everything the
practical and the and the spiritual if
you want to build a house I've just
built six houses last year before we
built the houses we had to see
in our heads we had to visualize where
everything was gonna be I remember
walking around the beetle arms and I'm
gonna sing it I saw it as exactly as if
it was there when it wasn't so it's
gonna be housed right here there's gonna
be a house here and there's gonna be and
then we have the plans and then we
worked with the builders and then
suddenly booming now do you like that's
how you build properties that's how you
build businesses you've got to write
your business plan and you've got to see
it and visualize it and write it down
and then you go make it happen so folks
this is not American personal
development claptrap this is just it you
have to believe it so much so that you
can visualize it and see it and write it
down and make it plain so that all can
see and you can see and then it happens
so do one of the people that think you
know that's clap track and that's
nonsense you want the people that put
the laughing meet the faces on Instagram
seriously change your perspective if
you're not if you're someone that wants
to be successful if you're someone that
wants to grow property business my
advice would be start seeing it first
don't wait on us I'll believe it when I
see it you have to believe it's so badly
right now that you see in your head and
then it's gonna happen
when you go into a meeting a business
meeting see what's gonna happen
visualize the conclusion of that meeting
visualize that I'm handing you the deal
visualize it and then go into the
meeting and then it happens that is not
spiritual claptrap
this is business this is practical and
this is facts if you're going to buy a
piece of land to build on it either make
sure that you already have planning
permission to build or you buy it
subject to planning permission because
the last thing you want to do is buy a
piece of land I mean I bought this for
this was too
three hundred three hundred and thirty
thousand pounds I bought this land for
that last thing you want to do is spend
three hundred thirty grams on a piece of
land that then you can't do anything
with so we've got Pawnee permission or a
day all through to build six houses on
it so it's gonna be a house right here
there's going to be a house here and
there's gonna be a third house here